en geometría uno de los temas que
podemos encontrar a simple vista es la
simetría está presente en la naturaleza
en la arquitectura en nuestra casa y en
muchos otros lugares hablemos de la
simetría axial la cual ocurre cuando una
figura se divide por un eje de simetría
y la figura que se forma del otro lado
es igual en tamaño y forma en la
simetría axial a cada punto de la figura
trazada le corresponde un punto de la
otra figura formada a partir del eje de
simetría de esta manera el eje de
simetría se convierte en la media triz
ya que divide justo a la mitad cualquier
línea perpendicular a las simetrías
axiales también se les llama isométrica
porque conservan la misma distancia
entre cada uno de sus puntos a cada
punto de la figura formada en el otro
extremo del eje se le denomina punto
homólogo y se representa con una pequeña
comilla
se conoce como prima para encontrar la
simetría axial de una figura piensa en
un espejo y su reflejo cuando nos
miramos en un espejo lo que vemos a
través de él es exactamente lo mismo lo
único que cambia es la orientación de
las cosas
vamos a construir la figura simétrica de
este triángulo lo primero que haremos
será trazar el eje de simetría y a
partir de éste trazaremos los puntos
homólogos para medir la distancia de
cada uno de los puntos al eje de
simetría usaremos una regla así que la
distancia del punto a al eje mide 7
centímetros
ahora vamos a marcar este punto del otro
lado del eje midiendo los mismos 7
centímetros y ya tenemos el punto a
prima mira al parecer los puntos beige
tienen la misma distancia vamos a
comprobarlo
si medimos el punto b al eje con nuestra
regla se tienen 12 centímetros hagamos
lo mismo con el punto ce perfecto tienen
la misma distancia 12 centímetros
marquemos ambos puntos del otro lado
finalmente vamos a unir cada uno de los
puntos para formar nuestro triángulo
listo terminamos nuestro triángulo y
tenemos una figura exactamente igual del
otro lado del eje con el mismo tamaño y
forma y por lo tanto con la misma
distancia entre puntos
ahora que ya conoces que es la simetría
axial dibuja estas figuras en una hoja
de papel coloca un espejo desde
distintas posiciones para identificar
sus ejes de simetría y algunas de sus
propiedades